now if you go to the doctor here in
southern Nevada you know how long it can
take to see your primary care physician
right now Nevada ranks 48th in primary
care physician per person eight news now
reporter Brian will telling us about a
program that is trying to help address
that shortage let's do
medical residents receive their white
coats on Friday celebrating a milestone
on their journey to become a doctor this
is the first class of graduate medical
education training here at the roses and
so we're honoring them with their first
long white coat which is the symbol of a
practicing position this honor marks the
beginning of their career and a way to
address the physician shortages
something now Dr Olivio O'Keefe knows
all too well there's definitely a doctor
shortage here in Vegas even just even
though there's just 12 of us but each
year there'll be more residents coming
in and at least that's doing something
to address the shortage and yeah so I'm
happy to be here to be a part of that
for sure location of residency programs
plays an important role in where these
doctors decide to live and work nearly
60 percent stay where their residency
was located this program is really
designed to create a training program
that then trains Physicians who want to
be here who want to stay here who want
to practice here these resident doctors
will spend at least the next three years
in southern Nevada and 12 residents will
be added each year in 2023 2024 and 2025
to reach the full of 36 residents so
excited to come back home you know it's
great to experience other places but you
just know home is you know where you're
supposed to be so I'm very excited